é um vai e toma vai toma só gostosas vai
tomar é capaz dessa forma se gay sou eu
é hoje um vídeo muito especial muito
como vocês podem ver pelo título e pela
também nela eu ganhei um foco um carro é
que não só eu não comprei o carro nem
sequer tenha carta de condução bié e não
saiu não saiu de um carro nunca buscou
sua lewis quinta agora uns dias atrás eu
eo caso e fomos convidados pela cics
para ir a um evento na holanda porque eu
fui super heróis senão vocês vão ver
agora o uol e latim um mini concurso eo
prêmio desse concurso e vinho que era
vinho é o que quero é ver a minha visão
era um carro é que não é só um carro não
é um cartucho ninguém olha eu posso
ajudar acabei por ganhar o carro e muito
obrigado a pessoa que me ajudou a ganhar
o carro sem você já não conseguia
concurso é muito simples que não tem
essa foto integrante com mais likes
ganhava o caso era só isso que vocês
deram pra [ __ ] ganhar o carro e eu
consegui vocês vão ver o blog agora
vejam só mais um blog é na faixa vai a
primeira partida é sempre mais difícil
não é que nos interessa cara fofo mil
mas pronto fui eu que me dar o lance não
tem ainda no aeroporto agora temos que
já não era o oposto théo e caso tudo bem
convidou toda a nossa passagem a ser uma
crise externa não né
olha aí a nossa viagem do comboio
carregado e
eu vou andar de avião o que é um ponto
que eu posso morrer e o caso e também
podem ver de fora comigo e me machuquei
e bolacha mesmo tempo acho que tem muita
coisa em que a fé pode entrar no hotel
sol lá dentro já estava publicado de
medo de avião começou a tremer pra
[ __ ] estava a chover nuvens pretas
vai mesmo preto nuvem preta eu nunca vi
ninguém assim tom preto a enrascada
portugal ainda foi pior nem lá consegui
escarola né
olhem só a pro forma que exista foquem
bonita bom dia pessoal em teltow boston
e acabei de acordar já tomei banho
gostoso é por isso que o cimento em hay
no quarto eu não sei se está a apanhar
totalmente será muito grande
vejam só a minha cama bem gostosa uma
coisa que eu acho engraçado a equipa da
casa wanderlei supostamente quem está
aqui dormir e consegue ver quem tal e
tomar banho e até o jogo de sedução
ae olha pra mim quando eu tomo banho
fazer muitas portas do fundo nada então
vamos passear e poderá enfim espero que
vocês curtam deste blog não estou muito
habituado a fazer este tipo de coisas
que vamos chamar o caso porque eu falei
ou lado já vocês deixaram o pessoal aqui
já previa o cartão cada que eu tenho é
passar abril tanto jesus
este é o quarto caso pessoal não só uma
coisa se eu contrariei a e mesma bosta
mesmo ao contrário é a hora é barra o
quarteto 1111 catuaí
não vemos nada nunca tivemos nada trata
uma duas três quatro cinco singles em
detalhe uma tala e uma o caso ficou com
dúvidas então é uma cozinha e um biquíni
ainda acho que não não ontem não tem
toma chorar eu tive que fazer uma
receita não aceita casar época solapador
eu basicamente não ficou equipe durado
tipo assim eu vá com vapor d'água e
pílulas de um pouquinho dele
incumprimento matou da vida é pior merda
é do vendedor de dente é o alerta é
porque doía pessoal estava de barba
o caso teve um papel é o cão josé wilson
fundation furto e crédito rural do oeste
running to e epson além dos treinos já
secos também de um par de tênis para nós
fazemos o evento é assim a lei bem
gostoso né pai ruy carnelli uma coisa
que eu enviar um dentro do sapato quando
enviaram para portugal foi puxado com
concurso do carro que nós vamos conduzir
então sempre faz mais meu estou feliz
porque se eu subir faz barulho do carro
falei em função de cada um dentro do
sapato que me enviaram portugal e agora
vou conduzir conduzir não porque não
tinham carta e não tenha licença de
condução que tanto que eu vou com o caso
se houver acidente eu vou filmar tudo
tem um propósito e deixaram o iraque
também está aqui no quarto que é um
trinco em stream quem pop entender
mostra o teu livro caso
comprei mesmo psi ao tac nesta telma é
ana silva e franciela amizade com o ciro
nós o carro para chamar sol só fala já o
ex-ministro hotel porque porque no meio
do banda eu não sei se alguém fizer
alguma coisa e não só não vou conseguir
aqui
o caso mais grave já no ocaso o olhar se
assim no caso eo destino a bogotá
olha olha hora depois disso vamos tomar
o pequeno almoço e eu ocupo tenho caso
eu porque o caso na solidão aqui eu
estava em um bar com que na música que
aquela música que foi triste fundo
princípio casa e olhar para o infinito
tempo minha amada um cisma tem muita
graça desculpa casa ficou uma graça teve
então
[Música]
eu quero é o bem do nosso mais unita
quem tenha rendimentos quando nós
tiramos uma foto com o carro quem tiver
mais likes esposa tem programa ganhou um
carro pra casa botar a faca aí o caso já
te cuida provável caso da guiné mas
vamos tentar a nossa sorte câmara tem
tubos reator pessoal mas não só os
carros eléctricos
[Música]
não sou bem como trabalhos pedras são
bem bonito de cada sistema bancário novo
escuto os carros já têm os nossos nomes
lattek por aí
a idéia é que o frame casa e outro rosa
também dentro do carro e tatá e não é
tão bonito por dentro mas é f
lá a quatro pessoas entrou num carro
tunin
a nota militar de rondônia já com um
carro
só queria dizer que eu acho que o jogo é
no entanto que fazer as minhas últimas
palavras
à época foi canta cá o pequenino mil do
mundo e hoje que vamos morrer europa
senhora aparece a oi
olha lá senhora olha bom carro
ai que eu não fazia outra modificação né
então tudo isto caso assim seja mas deve
ser a estréia também está muito boa só
para ver os carros
isso aqui é uma leva de corintianos o
layout estudos
muito cansanço ganso teve comigo porque
eu só quero é que o capuchinho não é o
meu time eu prometi que iria hoje rui
rio a sua mota não nos cabe fazer mais
barulho ainda hoje pai tem um dois três
quatro cinco seis
ela e outras cada um mas dois tamanho
louco meu deve ser maioria no tcheco
lançou a polícia a entidade negou
anunciu e nisso e só saímos do carro
através de agora vamos não sei fazer o
que agora é o caso do cruzeiro portanto
cuidar do o cuidado casa cuidar só o sol
só então quando chegamos lá o edifício e
um filme em casa e cuidar da casa
só estamos aqui o edifício há imenso
frio aqui mas vejam só a paisagem tão
logo ele um barco chegando a passar
[ __ ] de culto pessoal eu vou atirar o
marcador está afinal é tecnologia anda
já disseram que nós éramos irmãos ea não
mas já sei que não disseram que éramos
irmãos disseram que éramos irmãos gemini
a então você foi cantado nos num
elevador se nós geramos irmãozinho
confiável
não vamos atingir o valor estipulado até
lhe perguntaram se nós geramos irmão
gêmeo foi nem possível que eu chamaria
exemplo só com o caso e entendeu meu
[ __ ] eu disse que nós temos pelos
óculos mesmo boné meu estilo mesma cara
muito gosto fifa atómica faltar o
contrário possui uma casa das bicicletas
encontrar me disse que ela estava
andando ao contrário do botafogo
estamos vivendo é um xodó
[Música]
vamos tirar a falta de água já que eu
vou colocar o pessoal vai te pms que irá
agora bem rápida bola no final não o um
tempo me dá só tem um buraco aqui de
vidro [ __ ] ser muito alto no cco é
dúvida
imagine esportivo diz a boca
putz até mesmo as fotos são paulo já não
ficar sem bateria e ainda tem muito para
mostrar
eu não sei se ele vai aguentar mas eu
vou tentar mostrar o máximo
vamos lá o cara tá muito e tentamos mais
alto em bola e só dá pra vir tudo de que
o caso é um caso
então já está toda em dinheiro
já passei da namorada antonia ramona sou
eu que joga só com lençóis e pdt e
monetária que fran e depois disto tudo
temos de estado caso tenham jogado um
pouco a passear ver o alunos gurn eu
acho que nunca tinha comido um amor tão
grande quanto estamos com medo era mesmo
gourmet tipo gourmet pequeno família que
o bicho que eu naco de carvão vocês
comem tudo' restaurante gourmet é que o
mais pequeno é sim diz também meu
outra coisa muito boa e depois disso
tudo nós vamos fazer tipo construir um
carro telecomandado né esse cara tinha a
forma do sapato que nós tínhamos que
pintarem foi muito louco série mas aqui
é o início
[Música]
cada itaguá 2 suposto carro passar por
cima disso e sim perceber ao possível
ainda tem aquela já falei o herói é o
rio
mas pintar o carro é meu eu tava
pensando em ser candidato nem fico mesmo
que com a ler ou e não seguir as regras
que fazemos no entanto o técnico
preparado e talvez jogada já estava azul
preto nova assim e eu vou fazer uma cena
de fogo
ela olha o canal 10 de israel
não não é esse o grêmio só no meu carro
basicamente eu vou pintar o tipo fogo de
turim mas com pouco e você tá apresentar
de provocar a saída é rápido e é isso aí
já está a construir um carro na bahia
caso tal um caso para caso
eu acabei de fazer uma aposta em 2008 e
assim uma aposta e agora é parte do meu
[Música]
não tem que se lhe diga
ae
i
basicamente o que pude porque com esses
teus anunciaram quer que ganhe o carro e
vim aqui foi em dó educar se é foi
brutal do evento só muito obrigada
queremos ganhar o caso a sério quando
carlos karam portugal eu vou fazer outro
vídeo a dizer que o cachorro portugal
que vocês vão vê-lo eu aqui mandar o
cara eu a pilotar o carro porque hoje já
vou ter carta de condução e eu acho que
ainda não é hora de pôr um mês ou dois
meses para portugal que vem muito bons
nem que o episódio portanto mora tempo
espero que vocês tenham gostado já sabem
passei no link estar embaixo quer jogar
logo que o meu canal fox eu vou começar
a postar mais lá
portanto é compreensível já que lado
vocês também têm dois filhos que poderão
não ter assistido portanto podem
aproveitar agora existindo e aqui em
cima vocês podem subscrever aqui o canal
the dark freio e fazer parte deste filme
life a imagem de com um shopping
milhão de inscritos muito obrigado
pessoal pra que vocês gostem do conteúdo
da frame do dark box no futuro e é isso
beijo na bunda ela e